if the Fallen are working their way up
the mountain their goal is to take
Bostock observatory what would the full
and walked in an abandoned outpost
things better left buried hello I'm
Justin hey walled and Destiny's rise of
iron is on the horizon and I'm talking
with Eric T who's played a substantial
chunk of the game Eric you how much time
did you get to spin with the game
recently I got to spend about six hours
unfortunately I can't tell you all of
the stuff I played but we can go through
some of the things we got to see that
we're allowed to talk about one of which
is fell winners peak it's pretty cool
it's the new social space you kind of
have to fight your way they're kind of
it's like a mission that leads you to
where the Lords of iron were so you're
kind of fighting your way up to that
mountain and once you ascend to the
mountain you pretty much open up this
social space where you know Lord
Saladin's there we have a couple new
NPCs we have a Shiro who is a an XO who
works for Cade six pretty cool guy and
also a new crib dark essentially a tira
Karn hopefully I'm saying her name right
I'm not sorry tier Tyra she's not real
she won't care but yeah so she's gonna
decrypt your engram so she's like
another crypt dark person and then it's
just really cool it's like this kind of
snowy mountain with this iron temple
where you know the Lords of iron used to
hang out at and like you know it's nice
fires everywhere there's wolves hanging
out like that's cool wool statues and
they just you can walk up to them and
just hang out with them and I don't know
I like wolves a very game of thrones
northern kind of feel yeah some of the
armors kind of got that feel too so
definitely going with the theme there
and it's just I think it's cool social
space and I assume you have more vendors
there who are gonna be selling your new
gear so the ever verse there's like a
kind of a station that you could buy
your emotes and stuff from um there's
not any vendors to really buy stuff from
Shiro does give you quests he does have
a few things you can buy from him and
then
and I guess the you know your bounty
persons there you have enough but like
all your faction people are still at the
tower so you're still going to like
there's still reasons to go to the tower
you know you have to have a reason to a
tower so not everything's there but you
know Lord Saladin's in fellow winners
peak now so like when iron banner
happens it won't be won't be going to
him in the tower he's actually in fell
winners peak but we also got to check
out the plague lands which is the new
area that kind of opens up if you guys
already downloaded the patch that came
out last week it kind of shows this new
area on earth to the right that's like
oh that's wasn't there before they kind
of like added it and I didn't get to
spend too much time there but you know
it's it's snowy again there's seba
everywhere which is kind of like the new
outbreak that the whole reason you're
kind of fighting and I got to try one
new patrol mission and it's pretty cool
because you ultimately one of your
teammates or if you're just there solo
will get to pick up that the flaming axe
and that thing is just like bees it's
just fun to wield and like the art to
like the smash it's just like you jump
up you pound the ground and just like
fire comes out so I was pretty fun it
wasn't like anything special necessarily
in terms of like what I was doing on
that Patrol event it was just like
slightly different it was like oh you
got an axe and you kill some guys but it
feels satisfying to use the ax obviously
and the space looks really big
unfortunately I didn't kind of get to
traverse too much of it but within that
space is the new archons portress which
is kind of like this base that's been
built by the fallen and there there's
the Archon Forge which is kind of like a
new event that you can now play it's a
weird kind of or I shouldn't say weird
but it's kind of like a hybrid mashup of
like a quart of Orcs and a challenge of
elders so for anyone that's played that
um it's kind of like horde mode ish so
you start it off with a key that you
have to put it into the kiosk and
there's different tiers of that kind of
like quarter forks and you basically
kill stuff until you get to a hundred
percent and each time you kind of
populate a like an arena they
they're different they have different
kind of enemies so one could be shanks
one could be servitors basically you
kill a bunch of stuff for mode style
until you hit a hundred percent when you
hit a hundred percent you're going to
end up having to fight like either one
or two kind of like like bosses and then
once you do that you kind of finish and
then it's meant to be pretty quick you
have to kill everything within five
minutes or you fail and if you die and
you don't get revived you get sent up to
the top and you kind of just have to
watch your teammates try to like win
without you but it's fun it's it's quick
it's fun and I was told that you will
get armor rewards it's kind of random
though so and I think the higher tiers
you do there's three tiers there's like
a green a key a blue key and like a
purple key we're only allowed to show
the green key unfortunately but it's
pretty fun it's pretty fast it's just
kind of like I want to call it somewhat
mindless I mean like I'm sure like the
the tier 3 gets harder because it's just
more demanding but like the green tears
we were doing was like easy peasy is
just a kill stuff and it's fun to kill
stuff you know use your supers in one
heart you're the core demographic for
destiny you've spent so much time in the
game I I think you were the first person
in the office to hit every milestone as
it was coming up but for someone who
maybe didn't spend as much time in the
game do you feel like this is a
substantial addition of content or what
is it that might entice people to come
back into the game yeah um it's hard for
me to say because I didn't have enough
time to check out all the content like
all the stuff that you would do after
story I think the story was great I
think that they did a good job because
like there's this book now that you
basically will fill out and as you fill
that book out for like finishing quests
or finishing different types of missions
and stuff objectives it's kind of like
the moments of triumph book and the srl
book but there's tangible rewards and i
think that that's very enticing to
people because at least for you like you
don't play that much but if i told you
hey if you finish and get to level two
you're going to get like a box with an
item for your class that looks cool and
it's going to help you out that is
probably pretty compelling it wasn't
like that necessarily before so i think
quality of life and stuff like that has
gotten
even better from taking king so I think
that if you are interested you're gonna
you know keep playing and if you're
already playing you're going to keep
playing not sure about the people that
haven't played at all like if it's
enticing enough but wat SI so destiny is
due out September 20th that's correct
according to PSN it's 2 a.m. we'll have
to see i'm pretty sure that's the time
though if you've already played the game
if this is just the expansion it's only
thirty dollars or you can get this as
part of the full package for 60 bucks
right that's correct and part of the
sixty dollar package if you haven't been
playing too much or you know you have a
character that you want to play now that
you haven't made yet or hasn't fully
leveled up it comes with a like level 40
boost as well I think once you boost
your 280 light which is about 40 to 50
less than what most people are now well
that's about all the time we have for
destiny rise of iron do you think you're
going to be able to beat Tay and beating
this expansion let us know in the
comments below
you